is there is um someone in the chat said
60 of married people used to meet at
work in the U.S and now 60 of married
people meet on dating apps that is
actually crazy
times though isn't it I suppose people
are busy now it's just easier what's
worse with that is that I think the
people who meet on dating apps only last
an average of like five years in a
marriage whereas people who meet at work
it's an average of 10 or more yeah but
do people go once it's like five is
around the average length of email
yeah it's like five they start that they
get divorced by seven it's like do
people go on dating apps or find
long-term relationships do you guys
think yes some people do I know one of
my friends got married and they've got
two kids they they met on a day nap what
what app was it do you know it was
Tinder really yeah it was but she it was
they had they had messy oh don't because
it's our business but yeah it was we
don't know yeah I know but still she um
yeah there was Tinder that they they had
met on I think women would probably be
way more likely to look for something
more serious
um than men would what I've noticed that
hinge do is that you have a section
where you can say are you like are you
looking for a long-term relationship or
short-term yeah relationship the weird
thing about it is you will get a lot of
girls saying figuring out dating goals
or looking for short-term relationships
and I think that's quite interesting in
terms of what women Aspire for
um what they're looking for long term
because the reason why I'm asking that
has it ruined dating like
as it made as it made human interaction
um a little bit more what we're looking
for frivolous like it's not it's not as
you know there's no meaning behind the
behind the connection it it it's it's
it's belittled to what human interaction
means because it it takes away a lot of
the necessary things that would make a
meaningful interaction because now it's
a case of like I said it's a picking mix
whereas before the guy who had the dead
hairline might have been a guy who was
appealing based on how he came across
because he'd learned how to communicate
with other people whereas now these guys
are Savvy on texting and then in person
they're just [ __ ] yeah right yeah so
you've they've lost the importance of
active communication and that affects
long-term situations I agree with that I
think it's a sign of the times because
we're losing human interaction that's
such a fast rate isn't actually scary so
we're doing so much we're looking at so
much time based on screen and you know
even when you go to the shops you no
longer go into a cashier you're using a
machine right we're getting so into like
losing that I think even if you look at
the younger generation they don't even
know how to effectively communicate it
or have manners or hold a conversation
that is Meaningful because everything's
so based on internet and I also think
that that's set a standard or a
precedent that people are now very
insecure because people are not really
living in their truth so they're looking
at this than the other and then they're
basing their expectations as you're
saying about women having a high
expectation of this perfect man but does
that even exist but you're basing it on
something that's false pretenses because
you've seen on the Internet influencers
or models or do you see what I mean so
when we're looking at these things
people are then setting standards when I
don't think half those people are even
real so that's what that's done and
that's the interesting thing I think
with with apps like Tinder and hinge it
gives women the false perception that
they can that they're a higher value
than what they are oh yeah because
having access to a certain caliber of
men even just a conversation
to a lot of women to lose them into
thinking that this is the type of man
that I can get this is what I'm worth
and then they end up sleeping this guy
but the reality is you know a woman is
judged with a man that she can keep not
by who she sleeps with
um so I think dating apps actually
delude women into thinking that they
have a higher value than what they're
actually worth because when you say that
it's because like I've said before
um women have a hard time
differentiating between the certain
types of attention so if if a woman gets
attention she gets attention she loves
it but there are certain men that will
give you attention because they want to
smash 100 right and there's a certain
men that give you attention because they
want to make you you know they're
long-term and I think
um the reason why I'm asking that has it
ruined it because I'm just like women
are getting
loads of attention constantly on these
apps right and I think it's warping
their sense of reality do you know what
confuses me so like I I used to be on
dating apps I don't use them anymore but
this is just like from what I when I
used to use them and I remember speaking
to one girl on on the stating up and she
was like um
she was a um a twerk teacher
as you can imagine her her profile was
this food field of just Beauty I've seen
cheeks and I'm like yeah all right cool
so I've slid in there dropped a little
bar here and there so now me and her
talking I've met this girl
and she was then upset
it's like why the guys always look at me
for one thing because you portrayed that
yeah as a twerking teacher not just a
twerking if you see what home girl was
wearing not a lot it was a Madness yeah
and obviously
when I've seen her
it was a similar situation yeah what do
you know what I mean so you saw her and
I just were out she was out and I was
thinking yeah no they were there
so she would shoot and obviously me I
like to have conversations obviously the
way we do podcasts we just like to talk
and understand your way of thinking
right so she's complaining why do men
always always see me for one thing and
you know why can't a guy just Overlook
my assets and just focus on me
but I'm just like don't you understand
that what you're portraying is what
we're gonna act upon well I've always
said everything is sales in this life
everything you sell so people are going
to ask you
um before you even before you even open
your mouth people are looking at you and
they're and they're wondering what
you're selling right and so if you see
constantly cheeks
skimpy clothes you're gonna be like okay
I can see what she's selling so people
who say to themselves or say to you or
me and say oh why do guys only see me as
flesh It's like because well that's what
you're selling but the thing is it's
gone it's just interesting because
they'll take a twerking class before
they take a cooking class right relax
and it's like you it's like you want to
be valued for something else but what
have you done to be valued for something
else I agree with that is it my
responsibility to see any different than
how you portray yourself of course not
because why should I see any differently
if you're gonna give me a certain
approach which is what you're
representing right now right why do I
have to have the responsibility to see
any different than what you're giving me
that doesn't make no sense do you think
it's the same for guys do you think that
if a guy is like constantly got like his
top off and his app showing and his
chest showing do you think a guy feels
the same way like oh my God why are they
only viewing me for what I look like no
I think that guys do that because they
want to be viewed as that kind of Mel
that is yeah going out and he's that guy
is because they want to show you that
they're out there to they're that guy
they're the study guide they're going to
sleep with all the women and they're not
showing you that they want to be a
husband well it's feminine it's like I
think it's kind of feminine when guys
take a lot of selfies and they're super
into appear like I don't know what so a
guy topless on on the Internet is like
it's feminine you say I I'm not a fan of
like the shirtless pictures
though that's the difference they I
think they think that we like that and
you get that a lot in exactly the same
as on day and apps you get a lot of men
with kids so you're looking at these
kids there's nothing over their face
that's just mad that it's just
unbelievable that they're happy and in
their head I'm sure they think the women
are gonna love this that they're gonna
do oh women do but I'm sorry if you're a
d if you've got a bit of something about
you you're looking at a man that's got a
kid their face out like I don't look at
that and think always go I've got a kid
no yeah I've got some but I wouldn't put
his face on the dating app no you don't
know but the thing is women tend to lack
that stuff yeah it's a sign of
pre-selection so if a guy has a kid it
signals to a woman that someone else has
someone I get that it's just it's just
too much but I feel like men if a guy is
commonly do something it's probably
because it works 100
so as much as I say like oh you know I'm
not a big fan of the shirtless selfies
they do it often it probably and it
works I wonder what sort of women
they're attracting by doing that do you
see what I mean do they care I don't
know women or women so I don't mean they
do care but in the long term if that's
what they're used to then when they want
to come and look for a partner and
they've just been used to getting their
top off and getting some action and
they're going to be confused I mean I
think I think if they didn't like the
quality of girls they got they'd
probably stop doing it but it's again
we're going back to the not looking for
long-term Solutions they're not looking
for long-term relationship some people
are seeking instant gratification
people are seeking relationships and
long term this is something interesting
I'm trying to find a torsha put in the
chat when you're talking about women
that put short-term on their profile she
says that's a mating strategy so she can
get access to the guys that are looking
for short term
right so she's saying like it's the same
thing when guys say they want a
relationship when they just want
something short oh okay because that's
going to attract them yeah so it's like
a mating strategy okay so it's like okay
I say short term yeah but I really want
something at the momentum like I'm
trying to lock him down right it's like
being ambiguous it's like the ones that
say figuring out dating goals I just
want to see where it goes like what do
you think a matter to do with that
information
I mean for me do you think women would
do it if it didn't work do what do that
I I'm I don't know of an opinion no no
like could we apply the same logic and
say like women do that because it works
I think no it must do because again it
starts the conversation the guys they're
probably interested in but the reality
is is
is the outcome by putting that the best
outcome for you and often the answer is
no but this is what I hate because in
that scenario women would then play the
victim like oh my God he did this and he
did that but it's like
you set the the foundations on on a
foreign
and it's like well if you are
put in that kind of stuff
as your on your profile right you're
gonna attract a certain type of man
you're going to attract if you attract
trash around you all the time and
there's probably something wrong with
you yeah and I don't think that's
controversial either but women it's like
I don't understand why it's so okay to
hit man
I was actually going to pull that point
out because part of what you'll see a
lot on hinge is gone because on hinge
you can have the there's a question you
can answer the question yourself so some
of them will say I'm a 10 Baht and then
put the butt wherever the buyers but one
of the questions I often see is prove to
me that and then you will hear the
answer for the girl is men aren't trash
or all men aren't [ __ ] or things along
those lines just blatant misinjury but
it plays the plate of His Banner I'd
love to see if a man said that through
to me so you're saying that in these
Zayn apps um Miss Andrea's just like
it's normal it's very normal like you
will see on a lot of women's profiles
but it's misogyny then this is normal
well I can't I can't see the guy's side
so I can only assume that
um they'll probably get canceled or that
you can report them I'm sure women will
do they're probably not answering on
hinge you don't have to answer all of
the questions so you you can make your
profiles like
long or short as you want and I don't
think the guys are answering all of
those long do you know what I mean
instead of just keeping it basic I'm
curious have you guys
um ever had a relationship start from
being approached in person
yeah yeah oh yeah cold approach yeah
yeah okay what like um yeah relationship
is not a relationship no no no no you
have
wasn't approaching a woman yeah yeah
come on man's got so speak
but that's the thing like do you do you
guys prefer that
interaction that human interaction or do
or do you prefer the interaction via the
screen no person yeah human yeah but the
thing is people say that but there's
less interaction via humans and more via
the screen the generation that as well
it's a different generation that now I
find that I've got Snapchat I'm not
really on Snapchat like that I've got
Snapchat ages ago because someone was
saying it's true that when certain
things happen in the world if you go on
the map and then you look at like the
hot spots you can see what's going on in
real life do you see what I mean that
that's why I like it for that aspect but
of course when you've got that profile
but people use like Instagram and
Snapchat as online dating it's just a
different sort of just different sort of
thing Instagram's the biggest thing you
know what's what's interesting for me
because
I've I've seen people say that they fell
in love with somebody right
from another place
on a screen they've never met the person
in real life like I so funny I knew this
girl
um previously not now
um
who had like a boyfriend quote unquote a
boyfriend that she'd never ever met in
person catfish in there have you know
it's watching no no no no no I'm not
saying she's a catfish but that that is
that thing how but I I'm finding it hard
to understand how you have a
quote-unquote boyfriend yeah when you've
never met them in person and that is a
world where we're moving into
because people romanticize the idea of
this because you see what screens allow
you to do is it allows you to fill in
the gaps so a lot of people will see
these guys online and you're not getting
the full story so it gives and if you
are really attracted to the game then it
allows you to say you know what I'm
going to fill in the gaps with what I
want in the ideal man so it's all a form
of projection this is what I want from a
man he's got the looks already he talks
to me I'm Gonna Fill in the rest of the
gaps which are what what what all the
gaps he's a nice guy he probably loves
me he's probably selling a dream over
the phone like because I can't wait to
see you probably lives in France
somewhere yeah see what I mean literally
just sending her I've heard that it's
worth for the guy like you got to talk
to her for months then you've got to
think what type of guys it has got that
kind of time to yeah to do that and and
that's that's the thing about the screen
going that far like why only doing it
closer why has he got to go because I
think it's I think it's easier to sell
women a dream over a screen 100 it's not
it's not easy to sell a guy a guy will
interact with a woman via the screen in
but a woman will actually get literally
like emotionally involved literally
through words on a screen do you know
what I mean I think like the the the way
in which it's quite easy to sell women a
dream
um goes back to you know Disney movies
and rom-coms and all this kind of women
can see things on a screen and fall in
love with it and fall in love with an
idea yeah it's the fact because women
will always fall in love with what they
hear whilst men will fall in love what
they see right so it's easy to for a man
it's easy to have that kind of lustful
look for this beautiful woman but you
know because men are forced to have to
live in reality so you know this ain't
real you know that you know what this is
a fun interaction for what it is right
now but it's probably not going to go
anywhere I don't really care what the
situation is but for that woman you're
allowing her to live within a fairy tale
or you're feeding into that delusional
bubble that most women live in nowadays
it's like you know like that Disney
fairy tale the outcomes you know I'm
gonna meet my Prince Charm and he's
gonna fly over and we're gonna go we're
gonna have a great time as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are monetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible